things like holding our breath Kate
Winslet held her breath for seven
minutes Avatar 2 the way of water is
finally here the next installment of
this epic story was an epic challenge to
make for everyone involved stick around
for all the goods number one we knew it
was coming it's called the way of water
you know you're gonna get wet you might
be hard-pressed to put it better than
these words from actor Sam Worthington
Sam wasn't sure what he was getting into
when he was asked to be a part of the
film but he knew it would be challenging
and he knew there was going to be a lot
of work in the water he wasn't wrong
Worthington explained that doing all of
that acting while holding his breath
underwater was brutal it's the hardest
thing I've ever had to do you're dealing
with the restrictions of freediving the
constraints of motion capture underwater
and you're trying to keep an emotional
Journey going while you're innately
struggling with the fear of dying number
two what took them so long it's been a
while since the release of the first
Avatar film and there was always a plan
for a sequel so what was the whole up to
put it simply Avatar 2 took forever
because James Cameron had to make sure
Avatar 4 was ready to shoot not
something you hear very often right
Avatar 2 producer John Landau said that
we did not have to hold here for
technology I think the first avatar
proved to us that we could be the
impetus to push technology to where we
needed it to go Landau clarified that
the delays happened because the
filmmaking team was determined to get
the scripts for all four planned Avatar
sequels written and finalized before
shooting for Avatar 2 even started
Landau said we felt that this project
was about getting the story right you
would never build a house until you had
the blueprint to build from the scripts
are that blueprint so we wanted to wait
till all four of those were there number
three Avatar 2 is already a record
breaker and not in the ways you might
think the way of water takes us below
the surface of Pandora for quite a long
time and this Fantastical Journey takes
on a new level of realism when you
realize the actors are usually
performing underwater and holding their
breath for some record-setting times
according to one of the film's
freediving instructors Kate Winslet has
a beastly seven minute 15 second breath
hold which is impressive this broke up
previous actors record set by Tom Cruise
during his six-minute underwater
sequence for Mission Impossible Rogue
Nation number four we want it we don't
want it we want it director James
Cameron struggled with cutting things
out of the film and with tension around
the final duration of the movie Sam
Worthington describes the film as 2
hours and 76 minutes long and however
you count it you might say that's on the
lengthy side director James Cameron
recalled I think there was a lot of
tension around the length because it's a
complicated linear narrative which is
the worst case scenario to try to cut
short one of the hardest parts of trying
to shorten a movie is keeping things
that don't Advance the plot but are
beautiful scary or suspenseful on their
own Cameron explained we could take
things out and then if I felt the Rhythm
wasn't right we could put things back in
place number five no it's not an evil
genius secret weapon underwater cameras
normally have a hard time capturing
images with the quality we would expect
from a big budget Hollywood style film
for Avatar 2 the way of water a special
camera system needed to be invented this
was because so much of the film takes
place underwater and because the actors
would actually be performing underwater
you might think it sounds like a device
from the world of Avatar but this
special camera is called the Deep ax
beam splitting rig even with this
special camera system using lenses
designed specifically for filming
underwater the production had an
additional problem there were bubbles
forming on the lenses number six no
bubbles please Avatar 2 actor Kate
Winslet explained that the underwater
motion capture process was extra
difficult for both the motion capture
system as well as the actors because the
actors were not allowed to breathe out
Kate explains then you have a helmet
with a helmet cam that's that can see
every single movement and muscle and
twitch and flicker on your face she had
it you're holding your breath you can't
release your bubbles otherwise it's just
a bubbly old mess and the camera doesn't
see anything which would mean having to
redo the take which is a little more
complicated than usual when you are 20
feet underwater it was yeah a lot to
learn number seven how do you not look
like a blowfish looking back Sam
Worthington expressed some of the actors
concerns when they were approaching the
challenge of filming so many underwater
scenes for Avatar 2 the way of water the
challenge was not necessarily holding
their breath underwater for so long but
getting any effective acting done while
doing so action that's you know this
Jim's wheelhouse it's how do you do a
motion underwater how do you look at
each other with such love when you're
you know 20 feet under the water number
eight these actors got all trained up
while Avatar 2 might have seen very long
delays in production sometimes an
undertaking as big as making these
movies just takes a long time part of
the long preparation was the extensive
training the actors had to go through
before they could safely or even if
effectively begin shooting The Story
actor Zoe Saldana said he had us working
with like world-renowned redivers for
weeks on end the actress added we were
holding our breaths and really getting
our bodies acclimated to the water and
to the kind of depth that we were going
to be shooting in it turned out the
training wasn't only effective and
allowed for the magic of the story to
come to life but provided some pleasant
surprises for the cast as well we
managed to break records even for
ourselves that we never thought we would
do number nine these two go way back
Avatar 2 director James Cameron has
worked with Kate Winslet before Cameron
directed Winslet in the film Titanic and
Kate has spoken publicly about her
struggles with James and the harsh
shooting conditions speaking about her
experience on the Epic movie Winslet
called Cameron a really tough nut to
crack adding there were times I was
genuinely frightened of him Kate has
also said he has a temper like you
wouldn't believe you'd have to pay me a
lot of money to work with Jim again so
it may have been a surprise to hear that
she was working with him again on Avatar
2. James suggested that Winslet was
willing to work with him again because
she had something to prove to herself
number 10. mirror mirror on the ceiling
Avatar 2 the way of water uses a motion
capture system to capture the physical
performances of the actors and bring
their animated characters to life this
motion capture system relies on many
cameras being able to see the actors and
track the movements of small markers
worn on the actor's bodies and faces one
of the challenges of working underwater
with this is that the surface of the
water when viewed from both above and
below forms a moving mirror director
James Cameron explains that moving
mirror reflects all the dots and markers
and it creates a bunch of false markers
it's a little bit like a fighter plane
dumping a bunch of chaff to confuse the
radar system of a missile to address
this problem the team discovered that
they could pour thousands of plastic
balls into the pool to cover the surface
of the water without preventing the
actors or the crew from being able to
surface when and if they needed to
Avatar 2 the way of water sounds like it
was immensely challenging to make but
also like it was a rewarding process so
what do you think what would be the
hardest part for you in making Avatar 2.
let us know in the comments below